Томос - наш, нова помісна церква створена,
молодий митрополит зійшов на престол.
Тож, православним українцям можна
заспокоїтися і святкувати перемогу?
Насправді попереду немало загроз, які можуть
звести нанівець досягнення останніх місяців.
Для багатьох українців створення незалежної
церкви означає позбавлення впливу Москви.
Водночас нещодавно Володимир Путін заявив, що залишає
за собою право захищати свободу віросповідання в Україні.
Тобто Кремль вважає: ставити крапку в цій справ ще зарано.
УПЦ Московського патріархату, яка до кінця квітня
повинна змінити назву із зазначенням своєї
приналежності до Росії, буде і надалі перешкоджати
будівництву нової церкви.
А це означає судові позови, погрози та боротьбу за храми,
громади яких мають намір приєднатися до нової помісної церкви.
Почаївська лавра ще до об'єднавчого собору
скликала вірян на захист обителі та заявляла, що
очікує силового захоплення і провокацій зі зброєю.
Окремо Москва веде роботу з іншими
православними церквами, щоб ті не визнали ПЦУ.
Перед митрополитом Епіфанієм стоїть вкрай складне
завдання побудови об'єднаної помісної церкви.
По-перше, заохотити приєднатися до ПЦУ решту
релігійних громад та священників Московського патріархату,
а для цього - розвіяти міфи, що їх поширює російське православ'я.
По-друге, від Епіфанія очікують, що він стане главою
усіх православних в Україні, й особливого ставлення
до його рідного Київського патріархату за рахунок інших - не буде.
По-третє, значно старші архієреї повинні визнати
главенство молодого 40-річного митрополита.
В цьому контексті актуальна проблема Філарета,
який досі вважає себе патріархом а, значить, головним.
Так, начебто через хворобу Філарет не з'явився
на інтронізацію Епіфанія, свого учня - і не взяв участі
у церемонії визнання його предстоятельства та главенства.
В результаті на престол молодого митрополита
садовили представник Константинополя
митрополит Галльський Еммануїл,
колишній предстоятель УАПЦ митрополит Макарій
та митрополит Вінницький та Барський Симеон.
Але вже через два дні на вигляд здоровий Філарет
сидить на першому засіданні Священного Синоду
по праву руку від Епіфанія - у білому патріаршому головному уборі куколі.
Саме від якості ПЦУ залежатиме, наскільки стрімко
вона розвиватиметься та чи отримає масову підтримку вірян.
Адже і київський, і московський патріархати  відтворювали
ієрархію й структуру православної церкви радянської доби.
Проте в томосі та новому уставі прописана
значно демократичніша колегіальна система управління
та обрання нових єпископів, а також - активніше залучення мирян.
Щоб створити по-справжньому сучасну церкву,
парафіям варто надати більше повноважень,
громади задіювати в ухваленні рішень, церковні органи
зробити прозорими та підзвітними, посилити соціальне
служіння, запустити реформу церковної освіти.
На думку релігійних експертів, Православна церква України
ще на роздоріжжі: чи йти шляхом справжніх реформ,
чи повернутися до старих норм ієрархії та влади однієї людини.